Halala ! Ce petit son fort agréable des gens qui sont en train de tondre dans le jardin...!
Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de votre crédibilité lorsque vous parlez avec quelqu'un.
Si vous avez suivi la chaîne du Mental Vlog, vous savez que le non verbal est un élément essentiel d'une conversation.
Peut être d'ailleurs que vous vous amusez à décrypter celui des autres, mais est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà poser la question sur votre propre crédibilité lorsque vous parlez ?
Essayer de comprendre l'autre c'est très bien, mais prendre soin des propres signaux qu'on envoie soi-même, c'est encore mieux.
Et c'est un aspect du non verbal qu'on a jamais abordé sur cette chaîne, entre nous, entre mentalos.
Voici donc 5 choses à connaitre sur le non verbal,
sur le vôtre.
[musique du générique]
Certaines études... lien dans la description... ont prouvé que plus une personne montrait des signes de nervosité, de stress, d'inconfort... moins elle était crédible.
Cela ne signifie pas forcément qu'elle ment. On parle bien ici de la perception naturelle que se fait l'autre interlocuteur.
Donc dans le cadre d'un entretien d'embauche, d'une conversation professionnelle, d'une conversation personnelle... on peut passer malgré soi, pour quelqu'un de pas forcément bien fiable.
Juste à cause du stress.
Faites attention à votre discours, aux choses que vous dites, parce que les hésitations sur des questions simples et franches sont très mal perçues par la personne d'en face.
Si on vous demande quels sont vos diplômes, ce que vous avez fait succinctement ce week-end... et que vous hésitez tous les deux mots... ce n'est pas bon signe !
De même si vous utilisez trop, si vous abusez des intensifieurs, ils auront l'effet inverse que vous vouliez au départ.
Les intensifieurs. Vous ne connaissez pas les intensifieurs ?
"J'aime vraiment beaucoup ce qu'il a, il est incroyablement bien, c'est fait furieusement, tellement ce que je voulais !"
C'est trop !
Dans mes vidéos sur le mensonge, je vous parlais aussi des gestes tranquillisants.
Je vous mets les liens de ces vidéos, dans la description également.
Je vous avez conseillé d’être prudent sur les conclusions à en tirer.
En général ce sont de bons indicateurs de l'état de nervosité ou l'état d'excitation contenu d'une personne.
Pas nécessairement de son honnêteté ou pas !
Sauf qu'ici dans notre conversation d'aujourd'hui, c'est vous qu'on décrypte. Consciemment ou inconsciemment.
Et la personne d'en face aura le sentiment qu'avec beaucoup de gestes parasites de votre part, essentiellement sur le visage,
on se touche un petit peu là, ici, comme ça...
elle aura l'impression que vous n’êtes pas réellement sincère.
Elle aura tord, c'est sûr, mais ce sera déjà trop tard !
Je ne peux pas parler dans cette vidéo, sans parler de la légende urbaine des bras croisés.
C'est une légende urbaine !
Il y a bien un truc que tout le monde est persuadé de connaitre sur le langage non verbal qui se soient réellement intéressés ou pas, ou même plus d'une seconde dans la vie, ce sont le bras croisés !
Tout le monde a une théorie, la personne est en train de faire une barrière, elle refuse le discours, etc, etc...
Alors ce n'est pas faux, mais ce n'est pas vrai non plus.
Pour être précis, ce n'est pas suffisant pour faire une conclusion franche.
Pour faire une conclusion précise, il faut avoir le reste, c'est ce qu'on appelle la base line.
Mais encore une fois, ce n'est pas parce que vous vous le savez que la personne en face elle est au courant aussi.
Elle va forcément l’interpréter malgré elle,  donc évitez de le faire.
5éme point, je me suis rendu compte que je l'ai déjà abordé, c'était sur les intensifieurs.
J'en ai déjà parlé dans le point numéro 2 avec les hésitations, donc vous avez un double point sans le savoir, et sans que je le sache.
C'est énorme !
En prenant conscience de tout ça, et en faisait attention maintenant quand vous parlez à quelqu'un, vous n'allez pas être moins sincère.
Vous serez toujours le même, et vous serez toujours authentique.
Mais en maîtrisant tous vos signaux, votre discours sera mieux entendu, vous serez donc mieux perçu, donc plus crédible, donc plus entendu.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous a plu.
Pensez également à vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore le cas.
Parce que ici, depuis 290 jours là, juste là, sur cette chaine du Mental Vlog, il y a une vidéo par jour.
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]